[Musique]
et notre invité du jour c'est vous
n'égale et bagayoko bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre notre invitation
vous êtes chercheuse président de
l'african security sector network
j'aimerais tout d'abord un moto2 par une
réaction après après ces annonces cette
intervention du chef de l'état français
au côté des présidents et l'union
africaine et de la cedeao ça c'était
important c'est cette prise de parole
entouré absolument il est très clair que
la france souhaitait acté son départ
n'ont pas de manière isolée mais
accompagné de ses différents partenaires
qu'ils soient multilatéraux un haut
niveau de l'union européenne sahélien
bien entendu ou internationaux puisque
notamment dans le communiqué le rôle des
états unis et du canada est également
mentionné qu'on a commencé d'ailleurs
parlé parlé mentionnant communistes et
ceux qui sont bizarrement mentionné en
premier lieu effectivement donc est-ce
que ça augure d'un investissement plus
important de leur part je ne sais pas
mais j'ai été surprise également les
partenaires africains qui ont rappelé
leur soutien envers envers les français
ça c'était important là aussi ce matin
emmanuel macron il y en avait besoin
aujourd'hui pour cette séquence oui
absolument puisque l'un des axes de ce
redéploiement qui est annoncé en réalité
depuis le mois de juin l'année dernière
c'est vraiment cette idée de sa et lisa
sion de faire en sorte de donner le
sentiment que les premiers acteurs de la
lutte contre le terrorisme sont avant
tout les états sahéliens auquel la
france affirme vouloir s'employer à
apporter un soutien
l'aca et lisa sion sans le mali est ce
que ça ça va pas poser problème assez
rapidement finalement si bien entendu on
voit toute la difficulté de l'exercice
puisque l'épicentre de cette crise qui
bien entendu s'est étendue et continue
de s'étendre
reste le territoire du mali et notamment
du côté de la zone des trois frontières
et du centre dont classe question de
savoir ce qui va peser sur l'évolution
de la situation sécuritaire au mali est
absolument fondamental à mon avis il y a
trois éléments tout d'abord la nature et
l'issue des affrontements actuels entre
les deux types de groupes djihadistes il
ne faut pas oublier 7,7 ce paramètre
très important entre le gcim et le liger
s d'autre part la réalité et
l'effectivité de l'offensive actuelle
des forces armées maliennes en lien avec
leur partenaire russe et enfin la
fameuse question des négociations parce
que les autorités maliennes ont toujours
laissé cette porte ouverte et la
question est de savoir s'ils souhaitent
s'engager véritablement dans cette voie
ou pas mais c'est le seul élément qui
pourrait contribuer à une certaine
stabilisation l'avenir du mali après
cette matinée qui vous lisent et s'est
construite à l'est pas arriver comme ça
on l'attendait depuis l'été l'été
dernier comment est-ce que vous
l'envisagez vous on entend certains
sceptiques s'exprimer on entend des
craintes aussi formuler et compris par
des voisins les chefs d'état voisins
votre avis à vous alors d'un point de
vue sécuritaire un l'avenir au reste
très incertain est liée aux trois
éléments que je viens d'indiquer mais
également à la recomposition qui en
cours au nord du côté des groupes armés
touareg signataires de l'accord de paix
c'est un paramètre très important et on
voit que les autorités de bamako ne voit
pas nécessairement d'un oeil favorable
ce qui est en train de se faire dans le
cadre du strate du 4,7 stratégique
permanent d'autre part bien sûr la
capacité des autorités actuelles à
élargir leur partenariat notamment au
sein de la sous région on voit bien les
efforts tentés du côté de l'algérie du
côté de la mauritanie du côté d' état
comme la guinée le burkina faso être
extrêmement important et bien sûr
vis-à-vis d'autres partenaires
internationaux au niveau de la politique
intérieure bien entendu la question va
être de savoir si le soutien qui reste
massive pour l'instant dans la capitale
de la population va se prolonger alors
justement